hello everyone and welcome to game 19 of
the 1960 World Chess Championship match
between Michael tal and Mikhail
Botvinnik now after that long game 18
and game 18 was the longest game in the
match botanique requested a timeout as
he really needed to prepare he needed to
meditate and figure out how to how to
continue this match as towel was still
three points in the lead and the Botany
really has to do something and he has to
do it now if he if he wants to even try
and get back into this match so towel
also appreciated this time to rest and
he also had to figure out how to
approach how to approach this because
even if even though he was three points
in the lead he still knew that it wasn't
it wasn't really over
so him and Coblentz they had a deal that
towel will no longer use efore that he
will now open this game with c4 and they
knew that botanique will definitely go
for a very short variation they didn't
think that he would go for some sort of
a symmetrical English he they knew that
he would do something they just didn't
know what it was so let's see the game
without further ado towel opens the game
with c4 and already kind of a surprise
on the first move we have f5 so Botany
goes for the for the dutch and as this
as the quote says above the board since
both Enix favorite system was the
Stonewall I'll refrain temporarily from
d4 so I might be able to ram the wall
with the d3 and d4 so Paul doesn't want
to allow both unique the standard
Stonewall structure with a 6 d5 and c6
rather tall goes for Knight to f3 and
then he will later play maybe d4 and e4
to attack to attack the center so nice
to have 6 we have g3 and now g6 and this
was the real surprise as a the tall's
knowledge botanique never played this
this is the leningrad variation and for
this reason this game is sometimes
called and it is called so and the
official chess games.com the fall of
Leningrad but
you know you'll see what I mean so
Bishop to G to Bishop g7 and now d4 we
have d6 Knight to c3 e 6 we have castles
castles and Queen to c2 toss says that
instead of Queen to c2 he did consider
maybe rook to e1 with the idea of
pushing e4 next but he didn't want to
allow Knight to e4
even though Knight to e4 might not be
great for black he just didn't want to
allow it as Botvinnik
did surprising with this line so maybe
both mean really really brought some
poison so instead Queen to c2 now
preparing a 4 but also stopping Knight
to e4 we have Knight to c6 rook to d1
and now Queen to e7
Rock the b1 tall tall wants to push b4
and b5 to kick this night away from this
beautiful c6 square and he thinks rook
to B 1 is a better move than a 3 as it
also moves the rock from the a1 a1
square where it could be become a target
in the future because this Bishop is on
g7 so we have a 5 prime ending be for
now comes a 3 again preparing before and
here Knights to d8 and there is no
longer we I mean there's no longer the
need to put b4 as even even if the pawns
expand on the Queen side there's no real
threat as the knight is still no longer
on c6
so instead tall strikes in the center
efore I would have F captures on e4
Knight captures Knight captures and
Queen captures on e4 and there are a lot
of ideas here in the game night to f7
was played tall says that he 5 although
it seems like a great idea because the
white doesn't seem to have the option of
capturing sorry capturing the pawn as a
bishop
5 is coming the rook is not 1 B 1 that's
that's not really true because you can
capture an after Bishop here you do have
Queen to d5 trick and after you block
then you have he captures on d6
now attacking blacks Queen and after
Queen to f7 white can simply retreat
Queen to d2
Bishop captures on c4 and now White has
a whole lot of options he can either
capture here he can eat
Knight to g5 started an attack because
the Queen is already protecting the f2
point he can go b3 develop a bishop here
too many options for white so but black
is basically basically lost here
so instead after Knight if after Queen
to be fortnight to f7 now preparing it
now comes a knight to h2 h3 again
preventing a Botvinnik from pushing e5
Queen to f6 and now comes a bishop to d2
if you play a move like King to g2 then
then comes d5 and d5 is a very dangerous
move because of C captures it captures
and now your queen is attacked but also
there's an opened attack on the bishop
on h3 and now I have to remove the Queen
now comes the Bishop capture screen
captures and after Knight to d6 it's
it's an extremely dangerous position the
the rook and queen are eyeing the night
here you have to defend it somehow you
can't move the knight because the F 2
point is hanging you could defend it
with King to g2 but then this night is
coming to d4 a 3/4 and it's it's an
excellent position for black
so instead Bishop to d2 now comes d5 and
now Queen to d2
of course you're not gonna capture on d5
because of the similar variation we've
just shown only the Bushman h3 is now
undefended
D captures on c4 and now Bishop to f4
towel is now attacking the c7 pawn
Knight to d6 and now comes Knight to g5
with a triple attack on d6 pawn rook to
e8 defending and here you will see what
what devious plan tile comes up with
just because a botanist played this rook
to e8 move and the idea is possible
because the rook is not placed on e8 so
let's see what tells ideas first Bishop
- G - there is no longer point of
attacking the e6 pawn so he transfers
the bishop it's now hard for black to
develop the bishop we can't really move
if if tal once he can always capture the
knight on d6 and then pick up the b7
pawn and the c4 pawn so you definitely
have to do something so rook to a6
preparing b5 power plays 9 3 4 we have
Knight capture
Bishop captures and now b5 so it seems
that all is protected okay the c7 point
is still under attack but al has a
different idea
he plays b3 we have one character son b3
and now Queen captures on b5 and this
was the idea now the Queen gains the
temple because the rook on e8 is
undefended
so rook goes back Luke to f8 and now
Queen captures on b3 so I'm grabbing
back the pawn we have rook to b6
attacking the Queen the queen goes to e
3 and now rook capture some b1 bishop
capture some b1 and now Bishop to b7
botanique realizes that there is no real
way of actually defending this point if
you play something like Queen to d7 at a
simple rook to c1 and really there's
there's no way to defend this point
you're gonna lose it anyway
so instead Botanic tries to create some
counter play Bishop to b7 and here
Bishop to a two-top could capture the
bishop immediate at the pawn on c7
immediately for example Bishop captures
but he didn't want all our Bishop to h6
now you're kind of harassed here by the
bishop you can't capture because of
Queen captures on f2 you could play f4
which is which is fine for white but
then you're opening up your King for no
reason and maybe you're giving black to
too much counter play so instead of
capturing immediately first the bishop
to a2 attacking the e6 pawn bishop to d5
defending now Bishop captures pawn
captures and only now Bishop captures on
c7
a4 as the pawn on e5 was attacked rook
to d3 and now comes Queen to a5 Bishop
to e5 offering some exchanges in the
center and here rook to h6 was played in
the game about tal also says that rook
to e8
was kind of a threat but it doesn't
actually work because after you play
this simply Queen to e2 and the white is
perfectly fine because now if you
capture you always have this rook to e3
and now it's actually black that's
pinned and white is a white will still
exchange everything and go up into an
endgame being up a pawn so after Bishop
to e5
we have Bishop h6 a similar idea
you can't capture because of Queen
captures an F - Queen - E - and now rook
the c8 and here it's very hard to find a
move for towel if you play something
like King to g2 you allow Queen to
before with the exchange of Queens and
then it's you know yeah it will still be
up upon but I will be able to do
anything here probably not so here
tell-tell again tries to trick both
meaning he plays rook to f3 and here you
have to play play very precisely but a
Botvinnik
is the once again in time trouble he
plays Queen to h3 and Queen to h3 seems
like seems like an incredible move
because black is threatening rook to c1
and it's very hard to prevent rook to c1
because the bishop on h6 is also
guarding the C 1 square and the Queen is
you know slicing all the way here it
looks like it's game over from Michael
Tao but here top plays a brilliant move
and this move is considered to be one of
the greatest movies ever played maybe
not
due to its strength but because it was
played in such an important game in such
an important match so what's the idea
behind tell allowing all of this feel
free to pause the video and try to find
Todd's brilliant move so as usual I will
give it a couple of seconds you are tall
beat Botvinnik play the player move so
for those of you who found the move
congratulations you have just defeated
Mikhail Botvinnik
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show here top played Bishop to
c7 indeed it seems like an odd move
what's the bishop doing here well for
one it prevents rook to c1 seems like
very a reasonable idea the thing is if
you play rook captures on c7 then white
simply plays Queen to e8 check King goes
to g7 and Queen to f8 is checkmate
and here botanique like he was in time
trouble the best idea would be to play
something like Queen to d7 gets the
Queen into the game and now Bishop to f4
gaining a temple on this Bishop on h6
and after Bishop captures rook captures
white would pretty much solve all of his
problems there's no more problem of rope
to c1 checkmate and blacks own D pawn
will be preventing
black from checking the white king on
this diagonal after the king goes to g2
but after Bishop to c7 botanic played
Bishop to f8 now stopping Queen to eight
check by blocking blocking with the
bishop
so here topless Queen to b5 and now you
see the real idea of the trip to c7 and
this is something that botanic missed
now again the problem of playing rook
captures and c7 lies in Queen captures
on d5 now whatever black plays in a
short series of moves for example King
to g7 Queen d5 check and now it was the
rope King Jake wink a person c7 it's
game over
but I'm Queen b5 Botvinnik responded
Queen to e6 but it's it's no better for
example instead of Queen - Queen - Queen
here you could have also played Queen to
h5 attacking the rook with the idea that
tells bishop is still under attack but
tal had a had an answer for this as well
simply King to g2 defend the rook and
now if rook captures on c7 now you get
Queen to e8 it doesn't matter that the
bishop is blocking because you're
threatening Queen captures on f8 and
after Queen to h6 blocking this and now
comes Queen e6 check King moves not 25
check King moves and now you don't even
have to capture the rook immediately you
could simply spit in your opponent's
face and play Queen captures on d5 with
check King has to move and now you play
Queen if I checking moves and out Queen
captures on c7 your Europe the exchange
or up two pawns this is completely
winning so after Queen to b5 by tau
bottom ik played Queen e6 and now we
have Bishop to e5 and now you see that
this situation is drastically changed
from the way it was a couple of moves
ago
now all of that all species are active
black doesn't really have any threats
and the bishop on e5 is completely
slicing through the black Kings position
Botnick plate Queen to c6 trying to
exchange Queens here we have Queen to a5
and now rook to e8
tile also was hoping for both meaning to
fall for rook Bishop captures on a3 this
doesn't work because of rook captures on
a3 and now after botany
Quinta c1 check King g2 and Queen
captures on a3 and now you get to Queen
to d5 check and now after King f8 you
get Bishop to d6 and this wins the Queen
on a3 so tricky move but of course after
Queen to a5 botanique still didn't fall
for that
he played rook to e8 now comes Queen to
d2 rogue back to c8 and here Tull played
his 40th move King to G King to g2 we
have kinked a Queen to d7 by botanique
and now h4 so now Tally's waiting for
Botvinnik to decide which move he will
seal as the game has to be adjourned
it's move 41 and Botnick after thinking
for a while he didn't have a lot of time
to think but he played Queen to g4 and
after analyzing the game for the entire
night it was in this position that both
eunuch actually resigned the game
without even continuing the game and it
seems like seems like a very odd
decision because it doesn't seem like
tal has a way to actually force a win
here but what week after spending the
entire night analyzing it
he's down upon and he doesn't see
himself winning the game he does give
one variation for example Queen to a5
and after Queen goes back to the 7 and
now rook to f6 and now it's it's very
hard to find a move or White will have
this one over rook to a 6 to a 7 and
then the g7 if if possible but black
also has to play something and there's
really not too much you can play he can
capture the pawn for example Bishop
captures on a3 but then comes the Bishop
to b6 and now you have to capture it
Bishop captures now Queen captures on d5
with Czech grabbing the central pawn and
after King moves now rook captures Queen
to f5 and now Queen captures pawn
captures and now rook to a6 attacking
the past pawn now rook attacks the past
deep on d5 rope to d4 and now d6 and
although it doesn't seem like the game
is over
botany considers this to be winning and
it is in fact winning but you know you
think that stakes being so high I mean
it is
all chefs championship that both we
would try to defend this against all you
know he is considered the better end
game player but you know for some reason
for some reason after about eunuch
sealed queen g4 he didn't even play it
he resigned before even playing it so
yeah that's game
number 19 I do hope you enjoyed it
botany definitely didn't as now after
after 19 games he's down four points and
Todd is very close to winning the World
Chess Championship what Nick now would
have to win a couple of games in a row
to get back into the game which he will
definitely try but we will see more
about this journey in game number 20 so
yeah like I said I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting game
thank you all